[Musique]
j'ai failli oublier de vous annoncer la
grande nouvelle
anna et thomas pour venir habiter à la
maison de couple au même endroit ça
marche jamais je rappelle que notre
fille et de la rue hormis son gentil
mais c'est bon là les miettes dans
nutella les fringues partout par faire
ça va j'ai déjà donné l'un si les gosses
c'est comme des cafards il fait chaud y
avoir yabuli par plus il faut que tu
leur pourrissent la vie a aussi dit que
ça lui non ma chérie c'est ton café
d'hier qui a séché sait rien sinon tu
vas prévu dans le lave vaisselle
tu verrais veille apador maintenant que
tu t'en dit qu'est ce que tu fous là je
le dis pour voulais pas refaire après la
déroute aux jeux n'ont pas fait de bruit
en plus tu regardes eu la fois le pot
[Musique]
bien dormi e super doit pas faire le
monde du show les oreilles
elle a complètement compris mon petit
mano agence te fais un petit joie vivre
ah non ça va merci tu es un amour et si
tu dragues et ont beau fils ça va pas un
coup je pas draguer mon beau fils tu
subis là tu vas parce que delta et tom
[Musique]